Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're going to be doing
a couple of things.
One, we're gonna be exploring
a internet phenomenon
that I already know that most
of you are familiar with,
but we're gonna be breaking it down.
And we're going to be revealing a secret
that I don't think that
we've revealed before,
about a video that we
made a long time ago.
We're coming clean about
something dishonest
that we did for a video.
And we tend to be honest.
We tend to try to be honest.
I think this is going to be good,
for, to get this off my chest.
I can't.
I mean, if it does come up,
it pops up in my brain.
A little shame.
There's a little shame,
because of it not being discussed.
So, we're going to bring
it out into the open.
I will say, just in case
we're doing something
that we often do,
which is we think that
we're saying something
for the first time.
And we actually, "Oh
guys, like five years ago,
"You said this on Ear Biscuits."
Our memories, it isn't
that our memories are bad.
It's that you essentially
have just an open channel
directly to all our experiences,
because we talk about
everything that we do and think.
And so--
There's a difference between
remembering something
and remembering if you've talked about it.
Right.
So, we apologize if we've
already come clean about this.
And I don't think, I mean,
there are certain people that
have been a part of my life
through the years who,
they've been, I forgot,
they've forgotten that
they've told me this.
So, they're telling me this
and the exact same way.
I mean, my mom does that a lot now.
Yeah, that happens as they age.
I was talking to her this morning,
she had her second cataract surgery.
And this was the seventh time
she's told you about the
second cataract surgery.
Well, she's told me about
five different times
even though her right eye,
there's something else wrong with it
that makes it hard for her to see out of,
they've decided to do
the surgery, you know,
to remove the cataract in that eye anyway,
because who knows in the future, you know,
there might be something else
that can fix that problem.
And then the cataract
will already be removed.
And you never know if it will increase
her range of vision in that eye anyway.
And what I just told you,
she has told me for the
first time, five times.
And it's not, I don't, I
mean, maybe it's an age--
it's what she's thinking about.
Maybe it's an age thing, but it's like,
it's the one thing that when
you start talking about,
"Well I had this done to my eye
"and I'm getting it done to my other eye."
It's just the thing that you talk about.
And it's, and when you tell
everybody that you talk about,
"Well you know, I'm having
this procedure done."
It's part of it.
And then, I mean, I guess it's
a good sign that I've talked
to her enough that I've heard
the same thing five times
because you know, I've been
talking to her about her.
I good news is, she's got her second.
She's got the second eye done.
And everything went well.
She, we still don't know
because it was yesterday.
If she's realizing any of
the benefits or who knows
maybe in the future as
technology develops, you know
there'll be something that
can fix the other problem.
And then the cataract
would already be removed.
I don't know if I said that.
Yeah, yeah.
I like that.
That's good.
That was, that was a nice reference.
So yeah.
Do you correct her, do
you correct her when she?
You know what--
Yeah, you told me that.
The second time I was like, yeah
you told me that, third time
I don't think I said anything.
Oh wow, I think you got
to say it every time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You told me that.
Well, it's just good to--
What's the update?
It's just good to have a conversation.
What's the latest?
You know?
I think success is just having
a conversation where she's
you know, she's processing
and you know, I'm trying,
I try to ask questions that
will get a different answer.
Yeah, well, speaking of old
people with bad memories
I was on Facebook recently.
That's nice.
And this is a choice,
because this is not a habit.
I mean, I'll find myself on Twitter
and I didn't even
realize it was happening,
but that never happens with Facebook.
I do not go on Facebook.
I don't have it on my phone.
Do you?
I have it on my phone
and the reason that, I had
it on my phone for years,
but I do not, I'm not a Facebook user,
it sounds like a drug.
You can make that argument.
I do not participate, however,
recently when I was trying to
contact people to be a part
of Jesse's birthday video,
I was spamming like family
and friends and old friends.
Got to go to Facebook.
The only way I can get in
touch with some of her old
friends was Facebook.
One of the reasons I do
go to Facebook at times,
and I don't know what this says about me,
but there's a couple of people,
first of all, if you do go back in time
to when we were first getting on Facebook,
of course, we were individuals on Facebook
and before, you could
have like a Facebook page
that was a brand, the Rhett & Link page,
the Mythical page that we have now,
we basically used our
personal Facebook pages
for promotional purposes, right?
During the early days,
writing the Facebook song,
posting that, that kind of thing.
Yeah.
And we, in the same way
that we were using Twitter
in the early days,
everybody was using Twitter,
Facebook, the only point
of reference when those new
social media platforms came
out at the time was MySpace,
and the whole point of MySpace
was to have as many friends
as you could possibly have,
you were ranked by how many
friends you had, so we were like,
of course, I'm on Twitter,
that's why you followed
everybody back on Twitter.
In fact, we both had this
thing installed on Twitter
where we would
automatically send a message
to someone who followed
us and automatically
followed them back.
Which has rendered that
aspect of my Twitter useless.
And by the way, we're
hearing this very deep
vibration sound.
Oh good, you're hearing it too.
Somebody is doing some
work, it's like somewhere
in the neighborhood.
Construction?
I don't know if you're
gonna be able to hear it
in the final mix, but if
you do hear an occasional
vroom, that's what that is,
it's not one of our stomachs,
but we're gonna do our
best to get rid of it.
So I went back a couple of years ago
and I unfollowed a whole
lot of people on Twitter
because of that whole point,
following four or 5,000 people on Twitter
is pointless,
so I was like, I'll only
follow people that I actually
not just want to be nice to,
I want to hear what they have to say.
And so, where am I going with this?
So what that means is
that Facebook for me,
I think you could have
5,000 friends as a limit,
we both got to that place,
and then I just maintained
this Facebook account
and when I go on there,
there's a couple of people
that I was friends with,
that I wasn't really
friends with in real life,
I think they were in North Carolina,
that throughout the past four
years of the Trump presidency,
seeing what they say about the situation--
These are friends of friends,
these are not fans.
Correct, correct, these
are people that I was
connected to in real life in some way.
Seeing the way they processed
the Trump presidency
was just a fascinating sort of like,
I felt like it was my personal tie
to a very different perspective
than the perspective that
I had about everything
that happened over the past four years.
You can dip your toe in,
learn a little something
and then take your toe out.
Yeah, but I'm not a Facebook debater,
I'm not gonna get in there in
the comments and that whole
thing, but I'd go and
see the people debating.
Lurk, you lurk.
And so that's why I would go back.
Well, one of the things I've
noticed especially this year
ever since Facebook
has now done the thing,
they've essentially, if
you're looking at Facebook
on your phone, they've
adopted the same practice
that Instagram has, or even
TikTok where if you click
on the video button on Facebook,
it brings up a full screen
vertical video that plays and
then the next one just comes
up and plays or you can swipe
and the next one comes up
and plays so basically
the same interaction
that you have with those kinds of things.
So you kind of get into this loop.
And this is not a new
phenomenon, but it's something
that I sort of rediscovered,
and I was like,
I think we should talk
about this on Ear Biscuits
because it brought up some
interesting things for us
and that is, the
phenomenon of prank videos
on Facebook combined with
the requirement for videos
to be at least three minutes
in order to get monetized.
Okay.
Now, there are--
Has rendered what?
A crazy phenomenon.
It has created this
interesting intersection
of people who are both
making a prank video
but also, okay, trying
to meet the three-minute
time limit, trying to
get to that three-minute
time limit so they can monetize it,
but they're also, like most prank videos,
99% of prank videos on
the internet, are fake.
So if you take a prank video that is fake,
and then you require
these people who are not
professional actors and in
my estimation don't have
a lot of insight into
human behavior in general,
like what normal rational
human behavior would be.
There's a self-exposing phenomenon.
Having to meet that time limit
exposes the nature of
the thinking and acting
and the execution in a way
that just is fascinating.
It lays it bare.
And I have a case study video.
I have a case study video
that I kind of want to lead
you through and a couple of
other ones that I can just
talk to you about, but
I want to show you one.
I find it interesting
that you went on Facebook
to do some political lurking,
but then a prank video pops
up and then you just found
yourself watching it, is what happened.
I'm not proud of this,
but my guess would be
that this never happens to you.
But I would get caught in just sort of,
I'll just get caught in a video
watching sort of just binge
where there's nothing satisfying at all,
I feel like it's the equivalent
of being at a slot machine.
You're like a toddler
in front of the screen,
that's like, oh there's colors moving,
my eyes are looking at it.
I think this happens most often--
It is designed this way.
Of course, yeah, I would
think this applies to,
this is why they made
the interface this way,
this applies to most people,
but TikTok is the perfect example of this,
it's just like, you just kind
of go into this vegetative
state and just watch a bunch of videos.
Scroll, scroll.
But not every other
platform is trying to do
the exact same thing.
Yeah.
And I'd fall victim to it,
and I dislike myself when that happens,
but at least I discovered
something that I thought
would make a good Ear Biscuits,
so at least we're monetizing it.
So you watched this
video and you're gonna,
okay, I can see where this is going,
but Rhett has not shown me this video
and I want to see it.
Oh, you shall.
But first,
you know what, the new
mug that we're selling
on Good Mythical Morning.
The heat-activated mug that
goes from totally black
to showing these amazing,
vibrant illustration
from our Good Mythical Intro?
It has proven very,
very popular, so popular
that in the last
conversation we had yesterday
about it was that, we were
having trouble getting enough,
getting enough made, I
mean, this is great news,
people want the heat-activated mug,
but it also illustrates
another issue which is,
when we introduce a new
mug, there's an old mug,
there's a limited supply
of it and once it's gone,
it's gone forever.
This has become a collectible, my friend.
The old GMM mugs are in short supply.
If you want to own a piece of history,
the days are fleeting.
There's three colors, we
got two colors right now,
the blue, slash purple, whatever that is,
the green and there's an orange as well,
and they all have
different designs on them.
And this is at the last chance
section of the Mythical store
so mythical.com, go to
the last chance section
and this is essentially
things that there's a limited
supply, and they're there,
and you can get them now,
but when they're gone,
they're gone forever.
Ever.
For ever.
Unless you want to go buy
them for more on Ebay.
Which, some people do that.
Mythical.com.
Last chance section.
All right, crack open
that laptop, and let's go
to Facebook.
I can see the title of this right now,
thief steals bike and get big karma.
With an angry face emoji.
Thief steals bike and get big karma,
that's grammatically--
Not correct.
But forget it.
I don't think it matters.
Just forget about it.
And is thief spelled incorrectly?
I before E, except after H.
Yeah, thief is spelled incorrectly.
Are you sure?
Yeah.
I'm really bad at that.
T-H-I-E-F is how you spell thief.
You're right.
So thief is--
Thief is incorrectly, steals
bike and get big karma.
That's not grammar.
Okay, there's more than just that
that's wrong with this, okay?
So I'll let the beginning unfold
and we'll get into the basic idea.
Okay.
Okay, let me make sure
that the sound is working
because that is an important part of this.
We're gonna clip this right there.
So it's a guy.
So when they come to steal my bike--
Chaining a bike to a chainlink fence.
He's in a ghillie suit, is
that what you call that?
Yeah.
Oh, right there beside the bike?
Yeah, so he's strapping a rope,
and the girl filming is, "You
think this is gonna work?"
Okay, 30 minutes later,
so he strapped this bike to a big rope.
A chain fence.
And here comes the guy running,
and it's, "Oh, a bike."
This is the guy.
And he looks like a fake
bush right beside the bike.
Right beside it.
It's like he's never seen a bike before.
Now, okay, so he's thinking--
He's touching the bike now.
He's testing the tires out.
There's air in the tires, buddy.
Keeps touching the bike.
He's checking the front tire.
And this girl filming,
okay, she's kind of behind.
He's testing it just in
case you're wondering
what's happening, the
text says he's testing it.
You want to make sure the
bike is properly inflated
and he keeps touching the bike seat.
Let me see how it rolls.
He's checking the sturdiness of the bike.
Okay, now, okay now he's got to deal with
the existential sort of
crisis that he's having.
He's got his hands on his
hips and he's walking around.
He's scratching his
head and then scratching
his chin, like the
classic cartoon capturing
of inner turmoil.
Yeah.
This is the worst.
It's like he's talking to himself.
Yeah, he's dealing with,
he's thinking about
the consequences of stealing this bike.
We know he's tested it.
No, no, no, he's thinking
about what a person
who would steal a bike,
but would need to take
a long time to do it would do.
He's looking up at the
sky, and he keeps stroking
his chin and looking up at the sky.
Yeah, right, okay.
Yeah, right.
This is such an insult to intelligence.
Now he's talking to himself,
look his arms are out, and he's like,
"I mean, there's no one here."
What?
Is he talking to God.
He's like doing a soliloquy,
he's getting on the bike--
Here he goes, here he goes--
Hold on, there's still the chain.
And there we go, ghillie
suit just strapped
it on, here we go, and
the way he even starts
the bike is a ridiculous way,
I mean the way that,
here we go, all right,
don't want to go too fast because I know
that this rope is tied to it,
so then, and boom.
Oh my gosh.
So he did stunt work.
Here we go, listen to what he says.
Are you okay buddy?
You okay, what happened?
What's this on your bike?
Oh it's like it's not your bike,
that's because it was tied up,
it was my bike, that
what you were doing, huh?
So he's chasing--
And he also runs across
the bush, okay, all right.
So that was it, three minutes, 23 seconds
of pure, unadulterated prankage.
Totally not fake, totally not acted.
Let me first just explore
a couple of things
because one of the things
that was very fascinating
to me was the comments, right?
Because I was like--
I would say, please, let the comments say,
my intelligence is insulted,
a six year old could
watch this and pick up
on the non-verbal cues and say this is not
how anyone acts.
I can't tell how many views this has,
when I watch it on my phone,
I think it was like over 50 million views,
I think it was like 80
something million views,
just to give you an idea of
how many people watched this.
324,000 people have
reacted to it with a like
or love, whatever, 40,000
people have decided
to comment on it.
Okay, please restore my faith in humanity.
All right, Mark says,
"The bike thief is not a good actor."
Okay, okay.
He even sounds like he's
wearing a microphone,
a real thief would have
taken the bike in a second.
432 people seem to agree.
Another comment here,
"This is all a lie, a thief does not think
"that much to steal something,
"was he so blind that he
did not see the red rope,
"the carabiner attached to
the bike since he inspected
"the bike for a long time and finally
"a camouflage net is
visible at that distance."
First of all, as some people
have corrected this guy,
the carabiner was placed
on there after the fact,
because the inspection--
Right as he was about to take
off, the bush comes to life
and snaps it on.
"OMG, your videos are so
annoying because you think
"we're all stupid and
believe they're real."
"If you're going to waste
all this time in making them,
"try to make them a
little more believable."
"Is it possible that this
lasts more than three minutes
"and the guy with the car was
there all the time watching
"while the one who takes
the bike shows that there
"is no one, there is no logic to that."
That's an ironic comment.
I actually feel better about that.
I don't and I'll tell you why in a second.
I mean at least the top
comments call it what it is.
And are seeing through this thing,
now none that you read have
the insight that we have,
as to why this is
happening, because of money.
But I feel better because of this,
people are seeing it.
But the system is still rewarding
this guy's efforts, he's
got a lot of Paul energy,
I will also say that, the
guy in the ghillie suit.
Paul energy?
Like Paul brothers energy.
Okay.
Just as a sidenote.
I don't know if that's a
complement or an insult.
Just an observation.
To the Paul brothers or to the guy.
Here's why I don't feel good about it.
Because taking the time to
point out something so obvious
is not something to be proud
of and it's not something
to feel good about.
Yes, you're right, I would
feel even worse about
humanity if there were
people who believed it,
and it doesn't seem that
anybody really believes
that this was a real thing that happened,
but it's almost like there's this thing
that they're also implying which is,
you know what, if this
guy was a better actor
I would have appreciated this video more.
And that's the thing that's
super-interesting to me.
That's true.
It's the fact that and
this is kind of what
I want to explore, is the
idea that this is a genre
of video, now first of all,
the whole fake prank thing,
which we'll get to a second
and how that personally
applies to us and what
we think about that,
and what the motivations
are for faking a prank.
But again when combined with
this time length requirement,
now I'm gonna talk about two other videos.
In fact, the two videos that
came up after this video
that were exactly the
same thing, just packaged
differently, the first one was,
there was this family that was outside
and they were working on
a car and they had a pair
of jeans--
Okay.
That they have stuffed
with something to make them
look like legs, and then this guy,
like a middle-aged
dude, took his shoes off
and put them on the end
of these filled up jeans
and then put the jeans underneath the car,
like he was working on it.
Scarecrow mechanic.
Then he got on the other side of the car,
so that when he talked,
it sounded like his voice was coming
from underneath the car.
And as soon as they get it set up,
a woman comes outside, like the mom
of the family or whatever,
and at that point,
it was obvious that it was fake,
because of the timing
of the way she came out.
There was no cut?
No it was like, okay, we're ready,
and then they swift pan and she's coming
out of the house and she's like, okay,
I got the tools for the car.
And she goes up to the
guy, and he's yelling,
he's like, give me the wrench
and she takes the wrench
and instead of handing it to him,
she kind of like tosses it under the car,
you know to kind of
play along with the idea
that I would believe
he's really under there.
First of all, the longer
that his fake legs
just sit there, not moving at all,
and they're both right next to each other
and the two feet are propped to the side,
the more obvious it is that he's not real,
and then of course, there's a person
in the driver's seat who takes
her foot off of the brake
and it rolls over the
legs and crushes his legs.
And then she's going nuts,
but the funny thing is,
she doesn't even look
back at the fake legs,
she gets mad at the woman in the car.
It's just again, it's a
study of human behavior
that reveals that people don't understand
human behavior.
Acting is not easy.
And we're not just talking about writing,
not talking about acting,
we're talking about writing,
because you got to plan this a little bit.
So one of the things that
keeps people in a good story,
one of the reasons that
you like the movies
and the TV shows that you like,
is because the way people react
to unbelievable situations
is incredibly believable and relatable.
It might not be that
it makes a lot of sense
that people might end up on an island,
like they did in Lost
and not be able to tell,
there's unrealistic things that happened,
but people's reactions to the situation
are believable and relatable,
and that's what doesn't
happen in these videos.
A third video, super simple,
there's a woman and again these videos
came up, they were served to me,
Mr. I'm Watching Fake
Prank Videos on Facebook,
with a vengeance, they
were served up to me
because Facebook apparently understood,
he likes these fake videos.
Because you watched all of the first one.
The retention time was full
because I was studying it.
And you watched the second one.
And then the third one
comes up and there's a woman
standing knee deep in
a lake next to a dock
and there is a man behind her
and he has an aligator
head on a fishing line,
and he puts it in the water,
and he's like, hey, how are
the reservations coming,
like she's making
reservations on the phone.
While standing in water?
Standing in water, facing away from him.
And of course I don't
know who the person is
who's filming this interaction
and why she's not paying
attention to them, let's
not think about that.
And she says, oh yeah,
it's taking a second.
And then he's like, well,
you need to be watchful
when you're in the water
because there's all kinds
of stuff in lakes like, sea snakes.
He literally said that, alligators.
And she's like, "Alligators?"
Alligators are my number one fear
and you know that.
But she's not turning around to see it.
So he has to maintain, again
to get to the three minute
limit, which I didn't
talk about, the way they
stall that, the mechanic video
is she kept handing him tools--
Oh my gosh.
They had to pick the
moment in which they stall
the video to keep you watching
to get to that three minute
mark and in the gator
video, it's literally
just the husband moving
the gator around behind her
and continuing the conversation like,
how are the reservations coming,
for three minutes.
And then eventually--
Do you still not like gators?
And she sees the gator
and freaks out, whatever.
So I believe we said this,
but it bears saying it again,
you don't get paid by
Facebook for your videos
unless they break the three minute mark.
It's created a prank monster.
And you'd think it would expose pranks.
That's the point.
I think that's the underlying point,
is that Facebook doesn't care about this
because they make money and
apparently the people making
the videos don't care.
It's not like they take
it as a personal insult
that you find it fake, they just go
and make their next one.
They have embraced, my
theory is that people who are
making these videos
have embraced the fact,
of course it's fake, I'm doing my best
to make you believe that it's fake,
or maybe there's a certain
small sliver of the population
that's not that smart, that
does believe that this is real,
but we're all agreeing
with the fact that yeah,
this is fake, it's not that big of a deal,
but you watched it and I
made money so I'm gonna make
the next one.
And if people dislike the video enough,
these algorithms do
take that into account,
but you know, the main thing
is if people are gonna watch
the whole video, there's
no denying the fact that
it kept people on the platform
and it takes a lot to override that
and they're not gonna program
the algorithm to outweigh
likes to dislikes or ratio
or whoever they look at that
to whether you watched it or not.
The principle with Netflix,
it's a different thing,
but it's a similar principle, that Netflix
just started showing
you recommended things
that you'd think you'd like to watch
and leaning on that instead of the queue.
When Netflix first came around,
it was all about the queue,
it was all about I want
to watch this next,
this next, this next and you
would just go through it,
but the discovery mechanisms were,
they had a long way to
develop and they since have,
so now Netflix is mostly about that,
as are all of the streaming services.
And by the way that's
why YouTube subscriptions
have been buried for years.
For this principle that like,
it's not what's your stated intention,
it's your--
Behavior.
Actual actions that
are the tell-tale signs
of what's gonna work and
then what we can sell
the most against.
And this is actually, this illustrates,
I'm gonna make a political,
I guess you could call it a
political point at this point,
because this is an
example of why when profit
is the primary motive behind a process,
it doesn't, I mean, I
grew up a conservative guy
who thought that this
idea of the free market
and the fact that everybody
being motivated by money
will ultimately bring out
the best possible outcome,
right, like a pure capitalistic view.
I've since--
Competition makes everything better.
I've since re-calibrated that view.
I'm not well-versed on these
issues, but there's so many
examples in modern society
of how profit being the goal
causes things to, first of
all, it causes a lot of people
to suffer, I'm not saying
anybody is suffering
in this situation necessarily,
but you know, speaking of
Facebook and all social media
in general, we've seen
that this whole idea of
keeping people on the platform
and keeping people watching
ads has led to this incredible
political polarization
in our country, as was very well explored,
in the Social Dilemma
documentary on Netflix.
But this is just an example
of profit being a motivation
leading to a very bad product.
This hasn't led to a great product.
Have you no pride?
This has led to something that truly sucks
in every sense of the
word, fake prank videos
that are, fake prank videos suck.
Period.
Yeah.
Fake prank videos that are
drawn out for three minutes
in order to make a profit for the person
who has decided to make
a living in this way--
Are awesome.
Suck squared!
Which makes it kind of awesome.
And so--
I might get back on Facebook.
I'm just making the point
that that isn't the case.
I think that what makes
the human collective better
and is beneficial to all
of us is a better motivator
than profit, but again off the soapbox.
As a sidenote, arguably, our entire career
and success, post Good Mythical Morning,
or during, we're still
doing Good Mythical Morning,
but you know, post the launch
of Good Mythical Morning
is based on this algorithmic phenomenon
of watch time as well, you know?
Yeah.
We benefit from this.
But we didn't know that.
We wanted to have a conversation,
we formatted a show, we made
something that we were proud
of and our team is committed to excellence
and doing the best we
can and so very quickly
we arrived at, to have a
meaningful conversation,
you were at the 12 minute
mark, but we were actually
cautioned to not go far
beyond the 10 minute mark,
but then YouTube changed from
emphasizing subscriptions
to watch time and rewarding that.
So we made the best product
which started getting,
it broke 10 minutes,
got closer to 15 minutes
and people stuck around
and they watched the whole thing
and so we were rewarded,
because we rewarded the viewer
and they just kept binge watching,
we had so many of the episodes
that everybody won in that situation.
That's an example of the
content being motivated
by the system and the profit,
but making a product that
fits within that system,
that hasn't compromised
itself for the sake
of the profit.
We didn't know about the
principle when we were formatting
Good Mythical Morning.
But now, as we're reformatting
Good Mythical Morning,
and creating cuts for Facebook,
or making new sketches
that we put on Instagram,
we absolutely have to take into account
what's the threshold
to be able to monetize.
You know, we can't just make videos
and not be able to and
then platform refuses
to run ads against them.
So, Facebook, you know,
that three minute mark
means a lot to us too.
So if you're watching on
Facebook, and by the way,
that's how my mom watches
Good Mythical Mornings,
every I talk to her,
another thing she'll say is,
I've been watching more
of your show lately,
and she'll talk about a
video and I'll be like,
that video is like four years old, mom.
I was like, you need to
look at our hair styles
to really figure it out,
because the way that
Facebook will server it up,
it's seemingly random.
Once you watch an old one,
and sometimes we repost stuff.
Right.
But the main thing we're doing is we make
cuts of Good Mythical
Morning, cut-downs we call it,
that break the three
minute mark, but that work
within the Facebook environment.
But again, they break
the three minute mark,
but because they're 12,
15-minute episodes--
And that's easy.
It's an easy thing to cut it down,
it's something that we're proud of.
The place that we kind of relate to this
a little bit is Instagram.
You know, IGTV, there's monetization there
as well, it's in its infancy,
and it's not that significant.
But, the threshold for
monetization on Instagram
is two minutes, so the way
that we try to address that
is not by taking a concept that,
I think the thing that all these videos,
these prank videos that
I just talked about,
especially the alligator
one and the bike thief one.
You could tell this story in
a much more compelling way
in about 30 seconds, right?
Now, we create sketches that
from the conceptualization
and the writing and the
execution of the sketches,
it's like, okay, is this
a concept that makes sense
in two minutes?
We don't stretch anything out.
So yes, we are playing this
game, and this is a business
and so we're not going to take the time
to dress up and be characters
and make this video
just for kicks, it's part of,
if we can make this
thing two minutes long,
we can actually get paid to do it, okay.
So let's make it two minutes long.
But we have artistic pride.
That is questionable sometimes but--
No, we do, we do, we are,
this is something that we've always been,
I've always felt dirty about the system
and even, I think the best example of this
is the titling and
thumbnailing of YouTube videos,
which is a whole conversation
that we can have,
but just to quickly cover it,
you know the reason that
our thumbnails on YouTube
look the way they do--
Obnoxious.
Is not because we think
that they look good,
I mean just to be frank with you,
I do not like to see me making faces
that close up, I don't, I don't like it.
I hate it.
I'm pretty close to you right now,
this is like, I mean, I
don't even have to extend
my arm all the way to poke your eye out,
that's how close I am sitting to you,
and this is the
approximation of how close,
if you were recreating
the thumbnail experience
in real life.
Yeah, right.
I think psychologically,
look at me, look at me and do it,
if you're this close to me,
making faces like that--
You want to slap me.
And you were about to eat something.
Why would you make eye contact with me
while eating at this close of a range,
much less when making
that face you're making?
I want to, I want to slap me too.
That's not human, man.
Every time I see one
of our GMM thumbnails,
I want to slap me or
you, whoever is featured.
And I'm assuming lots of
people feel the same way,
but you know what?
They got a thumbs up, thumbs down,
they should add a slap.
Through doing this for a
decade and fine-tuning that.
We're slaves to that.
What we have determined is
that that style of thumbnail,
and there's a lot of different factors
that go into that style
of thumbnail working
is what gets us the most views.
So like you said, we
got artistic integrity,
but we are, we do play the game,
we are willing to compromise,
we do A-B testing on both
titles and thumbnails
every single morning,
it's like, hey this one
is not really catching,
we think we need to change
this word to this, that's why
if you watch from the very
beginning every day,
you'll see some changes
because hey, this is a game,
we're trying to play, we're trying to win
and we're playing within the system.
We personally are not involved in that.
Thank God.
Because we just cannot,
even talking about it
is demoralizing.
But the one thing that we couldn't do
is make that prank video,
I just couldn't, so we checked
some pride at the door.
We try to maintain some integrity though,
because while I do want
to slap you when I see you
on the thumbnail, and also
myself, so it goes both ways,
what I'm doing in the
thumbnail, what you're doing
in the thumbnail is not misleading,
it is indicative of what
they're gonna see in the video
and the title is also indicative.
They may be sometimes
just a little sensational,
maybe a little bit of a misleading thing,
but as a principle, it is
supposed to be indicative,
because we understand that
there's a long term relationship
that we have with our
audience, and if we begin
to mislead the audience and take you
as a bunch of fools, you're
not gonna stick around
for very long.
Right and that's the other
thing, that's insulting.
So we have a history with prank videos.
As creators, as artists.
And we couldn't bear to keep it up.
I will say, one of our first videos is
trimming strangers' nose hairs at the mall
and this was made before YouTube existed,
'cause we were making videos
when we were involved in
crew and we were hosting
or MCing the regional
Christmas conference,
we made comedy videos,
we talked about this
in the last year's and that's
where this video came from,
from the, I think it
was the Greensboro mall.
The Christmas conference
was in Greensboro,
and you know, it was just,
hey we need to make a video,
we made sketches, we were writing songs,
but we would also do prank videos,
it was just a genre that you did.
But we really did it,
we really took a nose trimmer to the mall
and wore these, you can look it up
on the Rhett and Link
YouTube channel and watch it,
I think, I'm pretty
sure it's still public,
it shouldn't be, it's horrible.
But the thing that's not horrible,
the redemptive value is that you can tell
that we really went up
to strangers and trimmed
their nose hairs.
People would, you could
talk people into doing that.
And it's implied that we're
just going around the mall
doing this, so I'm about
to trim your nose hairs
and I've just trimmed who
knows how many other people's
nose hairs.
With the same device.
It was heinous.
Yeah, but it never crossed
our minds that we would
fake it.
That's the beauty of it, the beauty of it
was getting the real reaction from people.
That's what we were into.
The fact that we really did it,
I mean, for me, whenever
we come up with something
like that, I'm like, this is go time,
we've got to show that we
got the balls to do this.
And to your credit, you
were right there with me,
but there was a lot more
inner turmoil with you
than there was with me.
I could just switch off my conscience.
Yeah, I don't like messing with people.
I have to make this work.
I would say that--
Because we've got to make a funny video,
we've got to do this.
It's not just that, it's not that you have
a stronger commitment
to making a funny video,
I think it's that you are
much more comfortable,
in life in general, in
making people uncomfortable.
And I don't know what this says about me,
but I have a real difficult
time making people
feel uncomfortable,
that's why I do the sympathetic laughing,
you know, like if you
watch, when we have guests,
and people point this,
like when we have guests,
when we used to have guests on GMM,
before COVID, we will have them again,
I'll laugh at everything they say
because there's this, and
I think it's just called
sympathetic laughing and it's basically,
you laugh to subtly communicate
that you're not a threat,
and try to make the
person feel comfortable.
I find myself doing that often.
I find it interesting
that in this conversation,
you're the one who's a
little more on the defensive
than me, but I'm basically the
one who is in these videos,
much more the willing jackass.
I'll watch that stuff back
and I don't want to be that
person anymore, it starts
to eat away at who you are,
you know, because I guess
I'll kind of switch.
But for the sake of these
kinds of videos, it's better
to be that way though.
Sure.
But my point is, that
was one of the factors
that took us away from doing prank videos.
The other one was, yeah,
because it starts to make
both of us feel icky inside,
to take advantage of people.
I think, my theory is that
it was a cultural change
that took place, not that prank videos
are not still a thing, but
there's a generational change,
and especially when all the other content
that you make is generally--
Nice.
Nice and good-hearted.
Like, you know, we try to uplift people,
our comedy is not cynical,
observations we try to make
about people are not
demoralizing or derogatory
in general, so then, but
we still have this really,
like, we're fascinated with
people and we do both enjoy
putting people into
uncomfortable situations,
and that's what our local commercials were
in a lot of ways.
We were walking this line.
Yeah, but screwing with
people at the dirt track race,
with the fake survey, remember that video?
That a lot harder for me.
It's much easier for me--
You're lying to people.
Right.
So you can laugh at them.
But it's a much finer line
with the local commercials
because we're doing something that's like,
this is gonna benefit your business,
and we're also collaborating,
this is an idea that
you either came up with
or you bought into, but
we're gonna stand here
and get you to say this line
knowing that it's gonna be
funny for reasons that you
may not fully understand,
I'm much more comfortable with that,
but when I have to be literally
interacting with somebody
on camera, it's just
harder for me to do it.
There's a cultural shift,
but at the same time,
there's not.
These videos are still going,
like tens of millions
of views on Facebook.
They're all fake.
They're not all fake.
And you look at the success
of the Impractical Jokers,
now that's an older audience.
I think it's generational.
The savvy feeling of feeling sorry
for the younger audience.
My kids loved Impractical Jokers.
And I think, correct me if I'm wrong,
I've never watched it, but
I think they make themselves
the butt of the joke a lot of the time.
They're primarily trying
to embarrass one another
as friends.
And they--
It's much more about that than it is about
making people feel bed.
They never leave the lie,
but even if they make somebody feel bad,
they let them in on the
joke at the end, I think.
They may do that in real life.
That is the principle of the big--
But they don't do that.
It's not, candid camera always ended,
like the old candid camera
show always ended with,
hey man, I'm just joking,
there's a hidden camera,
they don't do that
on Impractical Jokers.
They may do that off camera,
but they don't make that part of the bit,
it's just not a part of it.
I think the last prank video we made
just broke our spirit,
and we were like, never
again will we do this.
And so now if you haven't done it before,
there's a confession to make.
I feel like we need to make
the confession up front
because it will make watching the video
and analysis of it that
much more insightful.
This video is called invisible dog prank,
released on our Rhett & Link channel,
it's about to break 2 million views.
It was released February 26th 2013.
And there are elements of
this video that were faked.
Now, this video was a sponsored--
I don't know how sorry I am yet.
We need to talk it through.
This video was sponsored,
and there were these new headphones,
from, was it--
DTS.
Yeah, DTS had these new headphones called
X-Technology, it was
3-D like surround sound
and so we were gonna go
to their headquarters
which was out west of here,
and the ideas was let's make
a video where to demonstrate
how realistic this 3-D sounds is,
we're going to make people
think that there is a dog
about to attack them from
behind while they were doing,
I don't even know what we told them
we were gonna do, we'll
figure that out in the video.
Let's watch, we'll watch
the video together.
But yeah, I remember why
we constructed this concept
and then sold it to DTS,
and we can talk about that
afterwards, so let's
just, it's a three-minute
42 seconds video, so hey,
it could go on Facebook.
It's 42 seconds longer
than it needs to be.
This is Bullet, he's
actually a pretty nice dog.
But he's been trained to do this.
We're gonna make people
think they're being attacked
by him.
But it will just be in their headphones.
Here's the setup.
DTS has developed a
technology that creates
a realistic, 3-D like
surround sound experience
through just a pair of headphones.
But our test subjects don't know that,
they think they're just
coming in for a hearing test
in a focus group.
This is at their studio, at the DTS.
So we were playing DTS employees,
that why we had the shirts on.
Yeah, like testing new technology.
When we bring them into our testing area,
we'll have Bullet bark at them.
Scary dog.
And in the middle of our lame test,
we introduce the surround
sound of Bullet attacking them
from behind.
But when they turn around,
there's no dog.
Just a grumpy-looking cat, named Purrfect.
So first of all, we also got.
Is that Grumpy Cat?
No, it's a Grumpy Cat
lookalike, may he rest in peace.
Dude, was Grumpy Cat a thing a that point?
Oh yeah.
So we didn't come up with Grumpy Cat.
Don't want to give us that much credit.
But it's like, you think it's a dog,
and you turn around and see a cat,
this is a fun, fun prank.
However, here's what happened.
On the day, now they funny thing is.
Not on the day, in planning.
In planning, we were like,
this video has to work.
So we need some insurance
that if we don't get reactions
that are, you know,
shareable, and buzz-worthy,
we have to have a plan B to ensure that.
So you know, we were adamant
that we were gonna conduct
the prank legitimately.
Now I don't know if this is me moralizing
in my own head, but that
is not how I remember it.
What I remember--
I know that's what we did,
and then what we would do,
as we watch it, I might be
able to pick out people,
but I think what we did was,
we would get people to--
We just got people to do it twice.
We got people to do it again.
If we got them legitimately
the first time.
Yeah, and then if it wasn't good enough.
And then we said, hey,
"We're gonna do that again,
"now you know what's gonna happen,
"and just really, like,
when you hear the dog bark,
"just really react like you're scarred."
And we were like, hopefully
enough of these people
would react in a way that's believable
and we'll pepper those things in,
but there was a hope,
even while I was there,
there was a hope that
we wouldn't have to use
any of that stuff.
That we wouldn't have to resort to--
It was an insurance policy.
To directing anybody.
The only difference in my
mind is that we came up
with that on the day
that we saw that people
weren't reacting great,
as opposed to we planned it
like we said, at the time.
That's the only thing
I remember differently,
is that we were like,
"They're not reacting that great,
"let's just get them to do it
again and maybe we'll use it."
It felt like we were
really easing into it.
And I will say this is totally on us,
because no one who works for us now,
not even Stevie worked for
us when we made this video.
Yes, she did, she had just started,
this is February 2013,
and I think we hired
her between filming this
and editing this.
So she wasn't there during--
Or between getting the job and filming it.
Yeah, so it was like
one of the first things
she was involved with, but she
may have just been involved
with, I don't know if
she was there that day.
She may have just been
involved with the edit.
But she wasn't a part of
these type of decisions
that we were making.
Not at the time.
We were very adamant that we,
and I'm sure we were, that
we wanted to do the best
we could to actually scare people.
Oh yeah.
And then we just had a plan B.
Because the pranks existed at the time.
All right, so let's watch
it, and see if I can
pick out the places where it's fake.
Maybe that first one, that girl says,
"Oh my God!"
I think that was fake.
What's your name?
Edwin.
So we got the first guy coming in.
We're gonna do a little audio test today.
And the dog is, why is
there a dog in the studio.
There's dogs in the studio.
We were trying to set a mental cue that,
okay, there is a dog here
that might attack you.
So he was afraid of the dog right then,
because the dog starts
barking whenever he walked
through the door.
All right, just put those on,
and make that comfortable,
let's do it.
Hello, thank you for participating
in the DTS Audio preliminary sound--
Now this guy--
I love watching these,
they're obviously real people.
Right.
They don't come across
as actors in any way.
But this guy is an actor.
This guy was on Workaholics.
Really?
And multiple things.
The one minute mark.
Because here's what happens,
and people,
this is an interesting
phenomenon with prank videos
in general and I think
people talked about this
in the comments.
In L.A., when you put
a call out for people
to come be a part of
any type of focus group,
you get people who also are actors
and extras.
It's just because it's Los Angeles,
and that's what a lot of people do,
and so it makes it seem
like we hired actors,
because this guy, and at
least a few other people
are actors.
DTS Audio preliminary
sound perception test.
We will begin by testing your
hearing fidelity in each ear.
If you hear a tone in your left ear,
raise your left hand, if you
hear it in your right ear,
raise your right hand.
They're very serious.
Pause it.
Hold on, that guy.
The guy with the mustache.
The guy with the mustache,
at minute and 10 seconds,
he's in something.
A Tim and Eric thing I think.
Yeah.
For this next portion of the test,
we will be testing your
audio-visual location perception.
You will hear a tone and
its perceived location
will move from side to side.
See, we're really getting them--
Follow the perceived location of the tone
with only your eyes.
Oh here's Jason, yeah,
Jason was still working
for us then.
They're following with their eyes.
Here comes the cat in the basket,
that looked like a real cat.
And it is.
See, she knows this is silly.
Thank you, for this next
portion of the test,
we will measure your
frequency range perception,
you will hear a series of
tones varying in volume
and pitch and you will be asked to--
No, no!
Oh my God!
I'm sorry, that scared the out of me.
Okay, was that a real thing?
I don't know.
It was so good though, she was so good.
All right, this guy.
That was real.
That was totally real, that
guy shaking was real, man.
For this next portion of the test,
we will measure your
frequency range perception.
You will hear a series
of tones and volumes--
This guy is chill, there's
no way he's gonna react.
No, no!
Oh he did yell in slow-mo replay.
All right, pause it.
Now that guy threw the chair.
Fake.
I don't remember.
I got to say, I remember telling him,
because he was so chill,
he didn't respond.
We were like, now, like you said,
you see what's up now,
we were playing a joke on you,
can you do it again, and
again, it's not that we were
getting actors, but all
of these people responding
to these focus groups are actors,
so it actually played into
their psyche to get direction
to do something again.
They all took it, yes.
And I remember saying,
"I mean, maybe you throw the chair."
Maybe you throw the chair,
just put a little idea in your head.
That feels so dirty now, man.
That's real.
Oh my God, that scared me so bad.
See, 'cause she didn't even look, yeah..
That scared the shit out of me, man.
Workaholics guy.
See.
I thought I was being attacked by a dog.
That was real.
I remember I saw him when I came in.
I remember.
This is the guy from Tim and Eric,
remember we saw Jimmy
Sheper when we came in.
Yeah.
Oh my God, why would y'all do that to me?
We were all laughing at it.
That was fake.
Robot cat.
Really?
That seemed real.
If you thought a dog was--
Technology.
Yeah.
Attacking you, you
wouldn't sit in a chair.
If you just told them about the robot cat,
and the guy was like, really?
It's like a real cat, wow, technology.
Yeah.
He did a prank on the prank.
Are you serious?
What's the most scared
you've ever been in your life
prior to day?
My hands are shaky.
When my girl's pregnancy
test came out pregnant
and she was like 60.
We should hang out, you're cool, man.
I might have peed a
little, but I'm all right.
All right.
So first of all, there was no--
Sponsor.
Because there was no sponsor language
at the end,
because, here's the thing.
We were at a desperate point,
we were trying to scrap together a living,
we had started Good Mythical Morning,
but we weren't making
money off of it really.
So it was, I'm just saying,
we were a bit desperate
to feed our families,
don't hold this against us,
but you know, the final
product that we created
was not icky,
it actually had a good feeling.
But which one is worse?
It felt good, right?
From a moral perspective.
Let's just really explore this.
Which one is worse, one
that most intelligent people
believe was real, but was fake,
or ones that the person
who makes the video
has already dealt with
the fact that they make
prank videos, fake prank videos,
and they constantly get accused of it,
but they just keep making the videos,
and there's a bit of a
knowingness between them
and the audience that this is all fake,
but you're still watching it.
Which one is more morally wrong?
I know which one is a worse video.
The whole knowingness thing,
I just don't think that's
legitimate across the board.
I agree, I was playing devil's advocate.
So I don't think this is a fair question.
I mean, I never talked to Roman Atwood
about his switch, you know?
He really made a name for
himself with his prank videos,
pranking his own family and
I think other people too,
but then he totally switched
it to just like a family
vlogger, promoting positivity.
And then he totally stopped making videos.
I don't know why he made, he did?
He's not making videos at all?
He made a couple in the past year.
Talk about running the YouTube gauntlet.
Starting out with prank
videos and then trying
to figure out what makes people angry
when they watch it.
There's people who are just mean-spirited,
taking advantage of people.
There was lots of stuff
done in poor taste,
and I'm not talking about Roman Atwood,
I'm just talking about prank videos.
But he was, a guy like him in that world,
we sidestepped that world,
we just dabbled in this
one video, really.
Once we had a sizeable
audience, but then he jumps over
to family vlogging which
is another death gauntlet
of personal health.
Where you end up basically--
I don't know his story,
but that's my observation.
But you end up applying
the same principles.
If you're doing family vlogging--
Exactly.
And you're good at it,
you're making a reality show,
and everybody knows that
reality shows are fake.
So the situation and I'm not saying that,
and I'm sure that that
line gets super-confusing
and super gray of like, okay,
let's set this up like this,
it's kind of actually
happening, but we need to do it
this way for the camera.
That kind of stuff happens.
But--
It can eat away at your soul.
But the prank thing is just seedy.
I mean, I love Ed Bassmaster,
I've always been a fan of his.
He's still around.
But his pranks were always real.
We used him in a video as well.
And I consider him a friend,
like if I saw him now,
I would just be elated
to give the guy a hug.
In the way that I enjoy
Ed's videos at this point
is through Instagram.
I follow him on Instagram
and his videos come up
and it's like snippets from what he does
on YouTube.
And you know, he's still doing it,
and it's still funny.
But the heart and soul of
it is his characterization.
And getting people's response to him
and not just,
it's not first about putting
people in compromised
positions where it's like, it feels icky.
I mean, I think he'll go there.
There's an example that
you're familiar with,
because I'm familiar with
it, and I don't think
there's much crossover
between our audience
and their audience.
But because I have a teenage son,
I know about Nelk,
N-E-L-K, rhymes with belk.
And these guys, it's a
group of guys from Canada,
and their videos are so--
Full send.
I would call them full send.
They're the full send guys,
they're the full send brand,
it's their deal.
And their videos are so, let's just so,
distasteful according to
the YouTube ad system,
that they can't monetize
any of their content,
but they have long
since accepted the fact.
Over the edge.
They're not going to worry about that,
they make their money through brand deals
and merch and that kind of thing.
They would prank cops by
drinking non-alcoholic beer
while driving vehicles
and getting pulled over.
Getting pulled over.
Like baiting cops to pull them over.
So that feels icky.
First of all, I'm going
to go ahead and tell you--
It's not hidden camera
stuff, it's like doc style.
If you consider yourself
a Rhett & Link fan,
and you're into the
concept of mythicality,
and your general disposition in the world
is to make people's lives better
and be nice to people,
you might even be offended by the fact
that we're even talking about these guys.
They took, they went
out on a Big Foot hunt,
but then they put one of
the guys in an obviously
fake Big Foot costume,
and then baited this guy.
I think to the point where,
I think their main joke was
that he was gonna have sex
with Big Foot.
One of them was basically taken advantage
by Big Foot and then comes back.
Oh gosh.
So first of all, let me
just be very clear again,
I feel like we need to do this,
I'm not endorsing these guys.
I know we're talking about them,
and some people will go and watch them,
they got plenty of views,
they don't need our help.
They are offensive, if
you are offended by,
basically any way that
you can be offended,
you will be offended by these guys,
so that is my warning to
you, don't go watch them,
if watching people make
jokes that make fun
of all kinds of groups.
I don't watch them, I
only watched the video
you showed me,
this is on you, but I will say--
And listen, I'd say I
watched four of their videos
in my lifetime.
So I'm just putting a
disclaimer out there,
that you're gonna get offended,
you're probably offended that
I'm even talking about them
if you know what they do, I
feel like I have to say that.
I'm grateful that we're not in a place
where we feel like we
have to justify ourselves
to do more prank videos,
where we're mitigating
our risk by rigging it
and feeling icky inside,
and say, "We're never gonna say anything
"about this thing, right?"
Because that was a
conversation that we had.
Everybody who's involved, you
can't say that we rigged this
because that's gonna erode any
trust that people have in us
across the board.
It's all on the table at this point.
Would we do it, do we regret doing that?
Making that video?
I think so.
I do, but also, it was 2013.
Like you said, it was
extenuating circumstances
and we didn't end up making a habit of it.
We knew that it was a one-time thing,
and we actually made a sort
of an unspoken decision
at that point to be like,
"Let's not ever do a prank video again."
Because we understand the forces at play
when you make a video,
and you're like, I want
it to be a great video.
And if you really wanted
it to be a great video,
you'll end up faking things
in order to make it a
great video, if you're us.
So it's like we try to
keep ourselves from that.
And we know we're not
willing to push people
as far as Nelk would push
people to get the real
crazy reactions, so it
kind of just puts you
in no-man's land where
you either do something
that's gonna be offensive
to a large portion
of the population
or you do something from a true offense
standpoint or you're gonna do
something that's artistically
so bad that it's offensive.
So we're just like,
"We're not gonna do
either of those things,
"let's just stay out of
that world altogether
"and make content that you
know, is mostly wholesome."
Mostly wholesome, mythical.
I think we can leave it at that.
I don't know if I feel any better,
but at least it's out there, hey.
We trust you to do with that
information what you will,
and maybe that will
include, unsubscribing,
unsubscribe.
Yeah, and I will just say for those of you
who are going to be
offended at me for giving
a very lukewarm endorsement of Nelk,
after you go and watch their videos,
don't go and watch their videos.
I'm saying don't go watch their videos.
Yeah, that's a good idea.
Okay?
How about that?
How's that for an endorsement?
I also have a rec so let's do that.
Nelk, right?
It's not Nelk.
It's something called Meat Church.
Meat Church.
That sounds even more problematic.
This is a guy named Matt Pittman,
I follow his Instagram, Meat Church,
he's down at Texas, maybe
Austin, or outside of Austin.
And a lot of people have asked me,
where did you get the recipe,
give me the recipe for
your Nashville hot chicken.
Well, I just got it from Meat Church.
You just click on their link tree link
in the Instagram profile, and it brings up
all the recipes, and it
also takes you to the store
where he sells all kinds of rubs,
and there's a rub that's used,
there's a dredge that's
used in that process,
and the recipe.
This is also where I got the recipe
for how I did--
Green bean casserole?
How I've done some ribs and brisket,
and that kind of thing.
He's basically, he's
got a YouTube channel.
Anyway, that's where
I got the recipe from,
if you're into smoking,
barbecue and meats.
I'm getting hungry right now.
Check out Meat Church and I do recommend
all the products because
you can go to certain places
and get recipes for your own rubs,
which I respect, the
make your own rub game,
but it's easier to just buy your own rub.
So that's what I find
to be more convenient,
and he's got some good rubs.
Meat Church.
Yeah.
On Instagram.
Yeah, I think it's also just a website,
if you search Meat
Church, it will come up.
#EarBiscuits, let us know
what you think about this,
join the conversation and as
always follow us on Twitter
@mythical, and follow us on Facebook too
if you want to get some
Good Mythical cut-downs.
But on Twitter, we put out questions
that we then discuss on this show,
if you want to be a part
and get a shout-out,
follow us @Mythical and #EarBiscuits.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the play list
on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.